[Music]
Master mode is here for the Legend of
Zelda breath of the wild and it doesn't
mess around it's painfully difficult
from the get-go enemies are stronger
their health regenerates rapidly and
you're gonna find high-level enemies in
places you never would have thought
possible
if you play it on the standard
difficulty all of these changes mean
that you will have to tackle objectives
big and small alike in new ways charging
into battle like you're used to is not a
good idea to get you started we've
gathered nine tips to consider when you
set out in master mode and with any luck
you'll be on your way to becoming the
master of Ganon's domain and when you're
done with this video be sure to
subscribe to GameSpot for other breadth
of the wild tips including our guides
for the trials of the sword the other
main component of the new Zelda DLC
enough talk have at the tips tip number
one avoid combat when necessary rather
than fight your way across Hyrule
consider that you can accomplish many of
your goals without directly engaging
enemies all it takes is one or two hits
to die even against Redbook oblems at
the start so better to be safe than
sorry and find your way around enemies
rather than charging headlong into
combat tip number two
don't rush one of the biggest mistakes
you can make in master mode is sprinting
across the map and accidentally
stumbling into a group of enemies
be sure to tread lightly and observe
your surroundings to find the safest
path from point A to point B consider
every vantage point an opportunity for
reconnaissance and use that info wisely
when charting your course ahead tip
number three focus on shrines to boost
your health enemies will kill you faster
than ever in master mode so consider
focusing your energy on completing
shrines to earn spirit orbs so that you
can upgrade your hearts as soon as
possible
that way if you unexpectedly encounter
enemies you can stand and take a hit or
two before dying tip number four sneak
and steal it's true that book ha blends
will make quick work of you early on but
that doesn't mean you can't infiltrate
their camps and steal precious weapons
the trick is to run rather than fight
when you spot a camp of Aqaba ones with
weapons off to the side
sneak up as quietly as possible and
steal their equipment even if they
notice you
don't worry acabas we'll give chase for
a while and throw rocks to hit you from
a distance but a clever mix of sprinting
climbing and dodging will allow you to
get away unscathed tip number five
utilize your environment for stat boosts
cooking and crafting have always been a
core component of breadth of the watt
but they are almost imperative in master
mode collecting every resource within
reach will allow you to concoct meals
and elixirs that lend you greater speed
part of your defense or greater attack
power this should be obvious to anyone
who spent time in breadth of the wild
but it bears repeating given how even
the smallest advantage in master mode is
worthy of your time and attention
tip number six head to Hyrule Field for
DLC equipment given that enemies are
super tough now why not make a beeline
for Majora's Mask one of the new pieces
of gear in this DLC to make it easier to
walk amongst monsters without raising
their ire look to the e X treasure
ancient Mass side quest to decipher its
location and while you're at it be sure
to go for the e X treasure Fantasma side
quest as well the phantom armor you
earned carries a defense rating of eight
which is far better than any other armor
you can find early on it's important to
note that you first need to leave the
opening area the grey plateau and
subsequently encounter a loading screen
before these quests unlock an easy way
to trigger a loading screen is by fast
traveling to a shrine or tower tip
number seven amiibo are your amigos once
the option becomes available you can
always dive headlong into amiibo farming
to acquire lots of rupees food resources
and perhaps even new gear it's not
exactly playing fair but you'll need all
the help you can get to make it through
master mode tip number eight look for
floating platforms with metallic
treasure chests the new floating
platforms that dot Hyrule are a great
resource for strong gear with stat
bonuses most items you find within will
have significantly increased
capabilities and may give you a fighting
chance against the most harder than
usual enemies and lastly tip number 9
use bodies of water to drown enemies if
you can knock an enemy into water
there's a good chance they will drown
and die instantly use this to your
advantage and place bombs near the edge
of a body of water lure enemies to the
location and blow them up from behind to
send them sky rocketing into the air and
into the drink then all that's left is
to harvest their body parts like the
sick monkey you are
these are nine of our favorite tips for
beginning in breath of the wilds master
mode so thank you for watching and
sticking around to the end and if you've
got any tips of your own to share put
them in the comments below and as always
give us a like every little bit helps
[Music]
you